so when you start to see uh some of the
contagion that's actually happening
across the market uh is a lot of this
just based on leverage or like how would
you uh if you were a doctor trying to
diagnose the problem we see what the
side effects are in terms of a lot of
the contagion but like where can you
pinpoint exactly what has driven this or
caused a lot of the issues
yeah so a lot of the leverage um in
previous market cycles was was in these
derivative markets that were built out
you can think of the bitnexus of the
world the finances of the world that's
pretty transparent we saw that this
cycle was with the rise of defy uh added
another layer of leverage um so you had
all these funds um all these all these
kind of market participants that were
stacking leverage on top of leverage on
top of leverage uh and while and while
the you know the cycle was going the
bulmark was in full force uh everything
worked fine uh but on the other side of
this uh we're seeing a lot of that get
wiped out and purged and so i still
think there is some leverage out there
there is some bad debt that probably
ends up liquidated uh i think that's
kind of the slow grind we're in it's
just it's just purging the market of all
that debt
yeah it's fascinating to kind of think
through this you got some charts here
maybe let's go through those and then
we'll come back to bitcoin and crypto um
you've got the u.s equity plus all u.s
bonds market value uh not going so hot
big big drawdown here what is this
showing us
yeah
total bond market equity market uh value
uh basically lost from all-time highs as
a percent of gdp
um so historic drawdown and record time
um even surpassing the covid lows right
so you could just see we had this
everything bubble that's that's
deflating faster than i think most
market participants could have expected
um this is a result of of soaring yields
um obviously we know the energy and
commodity situation and so
not just crypto specific obviously i
think if you add you know add crypto in
here um it would be another trillion two
trillion dollars of kind of wealth
destruction um but but really you know
bond and equity markets have lost almost
16 trillion dollars and that's just the
u.s market so
include global markets and it's a lot
uglier so i think it's important to just
have some kind of context obviously
bitcoin's taking a beating but it's not
isolated and really it's about the
liquidity time falling out
yeah i mean this is just wild when you
see it it's more than the 2008 uh
financial crisis it's more than the
covid crisis just absolute off a cliff
uh drawdown there when we look at
treasury bond futures what are you
seeing here
yeah just kind of another way to
visualize this right the treasury bond
the u.s treasury bond is the driving
force and all global mark
it's uh it's still as king the dollar
still is king at the moment uh still as
a world reserve currency and so uh these
are long-dated treasury bond futures uh
and they're getting killed right so so
the bond bubble right people like to
talk about that green market bubble if
you want to think of like uh the
everything bubble but really what it was
was it was a global bond bubble um and
with with this record inflation um and
there was high inflation for a while but
as it continued to accelerate the bond
market realized you know these
bondholders you they were the patsies at
the table and so that's this sell-off
and bond is really what's causing this
pullback everywhere else um as yields
soar higher and people realize that um
you know that the net present value of
their assets as as duration gets killed
and you can think of the duration aspect
as as yields rise
so the
value of a growth stock why does it come
down when yields rise well when you're
doing cash flow models and you have to
account for rising costs of capital even
if in real terms it's still negative uh
with current inflation uh this is why uh
really this is like kind of another way
to view that liquidity tide is when is
when bonds are getting killed this is
treasury bond futures when the
long-dated treasury is getting killed
it's it's going to be a tough
environment for risk
we've got the dollar currency index here
and it's just up only uh looks like what
uh bitcoin and crypto used to look like
uh but now it's the dollar strengthening
against uh you know other fiat
currencies how do you look at this in
the macro environment
yeah so we can talk about consumer price
inflation now it's obviously top of
everyone's mind it's important to
understand that we're kind of in this
max paying scenario where inflation
inflation is soaring risk assets are
selling off at the same time that the
dollar which is the world reserve
currency is is strengthening against
almost all global fiats so the euro the
yen in particular um especially the yen
where the japanese the bank of japan are
conducting yield curve control
this is kind of that max payne scenario
for not for not us citizens but global
citizens especially emerging markets
with dollar denominated debt uh the
dollar source higher this essentially
plunges the world into recession so uh
the fed is the fed actually has uh kind
of a lot a lot of power um right now and
are making up for their policy error uh
with this this rapid tightening policy
so uh the higher the dixie go it's a
dollar currency index even if there's a
relative uh decay in the dollar's
purchasing power and real goods and
services uh this can cause a lot of a
lot of pain for global risk and that's
that's what's playing out
yeah i mean it's just crazy to watch all
this uh and the interconnectedness i
think of these various assets as the the
macro environment unfolds we've got bond
market volatility up and equity market
volatility up as well how do you think
about these two
yeah we're i think we're headed for kind
of a a point of singularity or uh you
know a reckoning point we've obviously
had a lot of pain in equities a lot of
pain and bonds a lot of pain is bitcoin
crypto um but i think
this all kind of ends or not ends but
it's coming to a head
uh with with a blowout in in spreads
below and volatility in the equity and
bond market and maybe even uh further
volatility in bitcoin even though that's
that's quite volatile um so especially
bond market volatility when you have the
most liquid asset in the world the asset
class uh the bond market trading uh with
this level of volatility not seen since
really oh wait we're surpassing those
those cobot highs as we speak
uh you know
the world's in trouble or really you
know global risk assets are in trouble
asset financial markets
and so uh probably equity market
volatility bond market volatility uh
explode higher and certainly don't think
that the high for the vix has been put
in uh and so
you know spell some trouble for risk
assets i think we're in a little bit of
a bear market rally here uh but most of
this stuff is the charts are saying that
the worst uh the worst isn't over
and how would you measure uh how bad it
could get like the worst isn't over but
is there anything on these charts
specifically around market volatility
that would signal uh okay this is where
my expectation would be is it just hey
where was the covet high or where was
the global financial uh crisis high
yeah it's tough to conduct you know
technical analysis on on volatility
charts with the vix i mean certain
people try to do it
and maybe maybe it works but i really
think what it comes down to it it's
somewhat
uh i'm not unfortunate but it's somewhat
comical that we're at this point where
we're all just waiting for a fed pivot
but essentially there's so much debt out
there there's so much dollars nominated
that uh and there's and yields continue
to rise where the entire world's just
essentially waiting for the fed to cause
enough pain for them to pivot um so
every time you see these these blowouts
and
volatility what brings it back in is is
easing a central bank stimulus it's not
a free market force um and that's
important to understand so i think
ultimately what we're headed towards is
an absolute explosion of volatility uh
and a reaction by kind of uh central
bank and you know a fiscal and monetary
response is what we're headed towards in
my opinion